You can just follow your "List" or check out
the "what's new" or "what's hot" tabs, or
you can dig a little deeper into the Netflix
archives to find some truly outstanding, under-the-radar
films.
Here's a look at some of the best stuff to
add to your queue the next time you don't
know what to watch.
The South Korean film industry is thriving,
and Revenger is one of their most bone-shattering
creative exports.
Directed by Seung-Won Lee, Revenger focuses
on protagonist Kim Yul, who's sentenced to
life in prison on an island known only as
AP-101.
The island is a dumping ground to keep the
most violent criminals away from society,
and supposedly impossible to escape from.
But here's the twist: Yul isn't trying to
get out.
He got himself thrown into AP-101 on purpose
to find the man responsible for the brutal
murders of his family and avenge their deaths.
He quickly connects with other inmates who
were wrongfully sentenced and puts his investigative
skills, and his combat expertise, to good
use to complete his mission.
The plot of Revenger is certainly predictable
enough to anyone who enjoys action films,
but the fight scenes are packed with the kind
of choreography that will make you ask "Wait,
how did he do that?"
It's hard to take your eyes off the insanely
talented star, Bruce Khan, as he takes down
the bad guys one by one.
Based on a true story, Solo was originally
released in Spain in August 2018, and now,
Netflix is bringing it to international audiences.
When Álvaro wakes up hungover and depressed
in his Jeep in the Canary Islands, all he
can think about is the fight he just had with
his girlfriend and his newfound discovery
that his close friend Nelo is leaving him
behind to move to Canada.
He decides to grab his surfboard and catch
a few waves to get his mind off everything,
but on his way down to the beach, he falls
and slides down the cliffs into the water
crashing against the rocks below.
He hits his head and begins hallucinating,
reflecting on his life and his relationships
as he struggles to keep breathing.
In Solo, the gorgeous setting of the Canary
Islands suddenly becomes foreboding and dangerous.
Solo is the kind of film that prompts you
to consider what would run through your mind
if you were fighting for survival it's not
an easy watch, but one that will stay with
you.
Not only is Lionheart the first Nigerian Netflix
original, it's also Nigerian superstar Genevieve
Nnaji's directorial debut and she just so
happens to be the star of the film as well,
putting her talents on full display.
When her father has to step back from running
his transport company because of medical issues,
his daughter Adaeze decides she's ready to
take on the challenge.
And appoints her uncle Godswill, who proves
tough to work with.
When Adaeze and Godswill discover that the
company's finances are in shambles…
"Given our current situation… can you tell
us how bad the numbers are?"
“Bad. ... try abysmal, madam."
… they're forced to set their differences
aside and cooperate in order to save the business.
This lighthearted family drama serves up more
than a few laughs and a strong feminist message.
Kingdom is another solid Netflix original
out of South Korea, adapted from the webcomic
series Kingdom of the Gods.
This genre-bending series pulls its inspiration
from both historical fiction and creepy zombie
flicks to create a fresh and exciting storyline.
When a dead king comes back to life, his resurrection
seems to be the catalyst for a plague of mysterious
origins.
In order to save the kingdom, the crown prince
must accept that the fight for their survival
is now his burden to bear.
Royal politics and supernatural threats both
vie for center stage in this visually stunning
With only six episodes, Kingdom is easy to
watch in a single weekend which is ideal,
because once you hit play, you won't want
to get up until you watch the season finale.
And here's the good news: season 2 started
production in early 2019.
Close is based on the life of famous bodyguard
Jacquie Davis, who once worked for none other
than Harry Potter author J.K.
Rowling.
Directed by Vicky Jewson, the film stars Noomi
Rapace as Sam, a highly skilled bodyguard
who can make it out of any dangerous situation
unscathed.
Sam ends up being assigned to protect spoiled
and naive teenage heiress Zoe Tanner, who
is set to inherit the wealth from her father's
mining company.
"Take him to the kitchen … he needs to be
fed.”
“We leave in an hour.
you might want to change."
The two head to Morocco, where Zoe will supposedly
be staying at a high-security compound to
ensure her safety but they quickly find themselves
under attack.
Sam decides that being a protector isn't enough
it's her responsibility to teach Zoe how to
fight back and figure out exactly who's coming
after her.
Rapace steals the show in this film she's
a tough protagonist with a tender side.
While this high-stakes drama has been criticized
for a messy third act, it's entertaining enough
to invest 90 minutes of your time.
Directed by Steven Soderbergh, the sports
drama High Flying Bird is unique in both plot
and production.
For starters, it was shot entirely on an iPhone.
During a pro basketball lockout, rookie player
Erick Scott wonders if his career has already
hit a dead end, until Ray Burke suggests an
unorthodox business model that could revive
the sport and disrupt the entire industry.
Instead of relying on the wealthy team owners
to cave and end the stalemate, why not let
the players themselves take the reins and
run their own league, leveraging the internet
to independently broadcast games to millions?
"What you saw yesterday was just a glimmer.
A lightning flash"
"What could be the beginning of a whole new
industry."
The economic critique at the core of the film
takes High Flying Bird outside the realm of
traditional sports movies.
The biting commentary on the racial and class
dynamics within the world of professional
sports are apparent in real life, yet these
issues are often ignored by casual fans.
It's easy to see pro athletes as privileged,
but High Flying Bird questions the power structure
integral to this industry when the owners
reap profits off the athletes who put in years
of hard work, who really comes out on top?
Equal parts buddy comedy and moving tearjerker,
Paddleton begins with the diagnosis of a terminal
illness… but it's not an inspirational film
about beating a disease and going on to live
a happy life.
When Michael finds out that he has stomach
cancer, which his doctor deems incurable,
he has no interest in proving her wrong.
Instead, he decides that he wants to die on
his own terms, with the company of his neighbor
and only real friend, Andy.
Mark doesn't have any major bucket list items
to check off there is no dramatic leap out
of a plane, no declarations of love to a long-lost
ex.
Instead, Mark wants pizza nights complete
with corny kung-fu films and then re-enact
those corny kung fu films at an open mic night.
"A great battle ensues and Lou winds up for
what will be known as the Death Punch."
He also wants to hang out with Andy and play
a few more rounds of Paddleton, a racquetball
game the pair invented.
A film like Paddleton risks falling into feel-good
cliches familiar to this general narrative,
but the refreshingly authentic friendship
between these two misfits makes the movie
something that goes far beyond the usual story.
Mark doesn't harbor any illusions about a
miraculous recovery or a triumph over the
impossible.
To journey through the quiet acceptance of
his own fate, he only needs the companionship
of a true friend.
It's a reminder that meaning isn't always
found in grand, sweeping moments, but in the
connections with those we love.
You're probably already familiar with Chiwetel
Ejiofor's from his work as an actor, an impressive
filmography that includes prestigious dramas
like Children of Men and blockbusters like
Doctor Strange.
Not only does The Boy Who Harnessed the Wind
mark his feature directorial debut, he also
wrote the script and appears as the father
of the young protagonist.
The film is based on the real life of William
Kamkwamba and the memoir that detailed his
incredible achievements as a young boy growing
up in a small village in Malawi.
Curious and inventive, William is barred from
attending school when his parents can no longer
pay the fees.
His science teacher, however, continues teaching
him and allowing him to use the library.
When his village suffers from a long drought
that results in famine, William must put his
skills to good use to create a windmill that
will power an electric water pump.
There are no surprising twists or turns.
It's a straightforward story that leads to
a conclusion you'll probably see coming, but
William's real life grit and ingenuity are
truly inspiring.
If you're looking for another unsettling sci-fi
series in with the same feel as Black Mirror,
Osmosis will be right up your alley.
This French series explores a future in which
people can use an innovative new dating app
to find their soulmate but it's not as simple
as swiping right.
Instead, this service mines data from the
user's brain.
On the surface, it actually seems pretty innocent
at first.
After all, if you could find "the one" with
perfect accuracy, without having to navigate
the complicated landscape of modern dating,
you'd probably be tempted to give it a shot.
But naturally, there are some unintended consequences.
As the developers behind the service warn
the participants, every experiment has a margin
of error.
While the idea behind the series isn't exactly
groundbreaking, the story itself is engaging
and suspenseful, and the futurist virtual
reality sequences make for some unique cinematography.
When it comes to sheer intensity, Black Summer
is a step up from classic zombie films.
In this series, the undead aren't lumbering
around aimlessly.
They're fast, they're hungry, and they're
downright terrifying.
In the days following the onset of a zombie
apocalypse, a group of desperate strangers
bands together, hoping that strength in numbers
will increase their chances of survival.
Sure, it sounds like the beginning of any
story about the collapse of society, but Black
Summer is relentless in showcasing the full
extent of the ensuing violence.
The characters don't get a moment to breathe,
and neither does the viewer.
Be prepared for nauseating gore and plenty
of jump scares.
Even if you only skimmed Lord of the Flies
in high school, you probably remember the
basic plot: a group of boys get stranded on
an island and attempt to organize their own
mini-society until help arrives, but it devolves
into chaos and tragedy ensues.
That's also the general storyline in the series
The Society, but this modern take on the dilemma
from the classic novel doesn't feel like a
mere rehash with electricity and iPhones.
When students return from a school trip to
find that everyone in their town has vanished
and the community is now surrounded by an
impenetrable forest, they quickly realize
that they're ill-equipped to handle what comes
next.
"It's nonsense."
"It’s Hebrew, it means you have been weighed
in the balance and found wanting."
Although teenagers are the audience most likely
to find the characters relatable, you don't
have to be a high school student to appreciate
the ensemble cast and realistic take on adolescent
conflict against an apocalyptic backdrop.
From the first episode, viewers are sure to
find themselves gripped by the mystery is
the town at the center of some grand experiment,
or have they slipped into a parallel universe?
Is help on the way?
And if it arrives, will it be too late?
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.